[Applaudissements]
sait-on ben ali c'est ce qu' ils me
l'ont là les y moi je vais réfléchir le
secteur des chiens selon philip wee moi
il y en a eu pas mal un des moments
renault mais je crois que c'est quand je
faisais mon one-man-show et à
quelques-uns y avait un type qui avait
eu la bonne idée de m'engager
j'étais pas de très connu pour une
espèce de conventions de vendeurs de
super quad renault et c'était
épouvantable ce que j'ai pris un four
mais mais quelque chose de pas rire tu
sais cette espèce de raie coûtera 100
seul milieu de gens tu dis mais je sois
je parle une autre langue soit vraiment
je suis pas droit de lingerie à paris un
merrien il était là et j ai je ramais je
ramais et jeu à la fin quand il
applaudit je salue je recule et j'étais
tellement vénère je me rends pas compte
qu'elle vide derrière moi ça qu'en plus
je me casse la gueule non
[Applaudissements]
tu reviens un peu un peu ensemble parce
que j'étais tout en saluant une deuxième
fois mais horrible et les lacs au dessus
de la bouffe et c'est mon papa merci
alors les pires au monde